[Music]
in this video we're going to discuss
committed use discounts and sustained
use discounts
we'll provide a brief explanation of
what they are how to use them and how to
track them in your billing account
let's get started first up committed use
discounts or cuds
provide discounted prices for certain
cloud services in exchange for
committing to a consistent amount of
usage for a one
or three year period there are two types
of cuds
spend based and resource based
spin based cuds provide a discount in
exchange for your commitment to spend a
minimum amount for a service each month
they are purchased and measured in terms
of dollars per hour
a limited number of services support
spin based commitments
such as cloud sql as you can see in this
example cloud sql cud
the commitment amount is defined based
on the on-demand price
you then agree to pay a monthly
discounted fee for the commitment for
the duration of the term
for some services like cloud sql the cud
is purchased for a specific region
and is applied towards all service usage
within that region
other cloud services apply spin-based
cuds towards all usage across all
regions
resource-based cuds on the other hand
provide a discount in exchange for your
commitment to run a certain amount of
resources
continuously each month for example
compute
engine cuds are measured in terms of the
amount of resources such as vcpus and
memory
and work on most compute engine machine
types including predefined and custom
machine types
you can make separate commitments for
gpus and local ssds as well
discounts apply to the aggregate number
of vcpus
memory gpus and local ssds within a
region
so they are not affected by changes to
your instances machine setup
like some spin-based cuds resource-based
cuds are purchased on a per-region basis
let's head into the console and see how
to view purchase and track usage for
your cuds
first up spending-based cuds we'll start
with viewing your cuds
for this task you must be a billing
account administrator or billing account
viewer on the cloud billing account
from the navigation menu select billing
if you have more than one cloud billing
account choose the billing account for
which you'd like to view associated cuds
then in the left-hand navigation menu
select commitments
on the commitments landing page you will
see a summary of your committed use
discounts by commitment type
to view a detailed analysis of a
specific spin based commitment you can
select it from the list
next up to purchase spin based cuds you
must be a billing account administrator
for the account
at the top of the screen click purchase
this will bring up a dialog box
choose the product in the drop-down and
then complete the details
review the commitment summary and terms
and then click purchase
finally to analyze spin-based cuds you
must be a billing account administrator
or billing account viewer
on the cloud billing account in the
left-hand navigation menu
select commitment analysis this page
shows the details of the selected
commitment for the periods specified in
the filter
including summary cards a stacked bar
chart and a summary table of the
commitments totals
more details on reading the analysis
page can be found in the documentation
linked below
next up viewing purchasing and analyzing
resource-based commitments for compute
engine
to view commitments for compute engine
you must be a compute admin or compute
viewer on the project in which you
purchase the commitments
make sure you have selected the correct
project then head to the left-hand
navigation menu and choose compute
engine
then committed use discounts this will
bring you to a list of your commitments
their status and additional details to
purchase commitments for compute engine
you must be a compute admin on the
project or
a project owner to purchase a machine
type commitment
click the purchase commitment button at
the top of the page
name your commitment and complete the
details then click
purchase to analyze your compute engine
commitments you can use the same process
as spin based commitments
this means you must be a billing account
administrator or billing account viewer
on the cloud billing account associated
with the project containing the
commitments
from the navigation menu select billing
choose the billing account associated
with the project in the left-hand
navigation menu
select commitments then click on compute
engine commitment analysis
this page shows the details of the
selected commitment for the periods
specified in the filter
including summary cards a stacked bar
chart and a summary table of the
commitments totals
this is also where you can change the
scope of your compute engine cuds from
project level which is default to
billing account level
with discount sharing enabled the cuds
apply across all eligible usage in all
projects associated with the spilling
account
any compute engine resources that do not
qualify for committed use discounts
automatically qualify for sustained use
discounts
sustained use discounts are automatic
discounts for running specific compute
engine resources
a significant portion of the billing
month
sustained use discounts give you up to
30 percent off
whereas committed use discounts give you
up to 57 to 70 percent off
suds require no commitment and are
applied automatically when you meet the
requirements through your resource usage
without any action on your part suds
will automatically appear on your bill
at the end of the billing cycle
you can view your sustained use
discounts on the cost
breakdown page located in the left-hand
nav
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
you